die reihen hinter mir haben sich
gelichtet bei der ard ist es kaum noch
jemand hier in kaulsdorf das
spitzenpersonal ist auch längst
verschwunden so viel gab es wird abend
gar nichts zu feiern für die partei bei
der abgeordnetenhauswahl in berlin klar
abgeschmiert in mecklenburg vorpommern
besser abgeschnitten als erwartet und
bei der bundestagswahl so lala
wahrscheinlich unter dem ergebnis von
2017 da hatte man sich natürlich einiges
mehr erhofft eine gestärkte rolle im
neuen bundestag zu spielen da die afg
für koalitionsverhandlungen bekanntlich
nirgendwo gebraucht wird ist das
wahlergebnis er ein vehikel für den
möglicherweise jetzt wieder
aufflammenden machtkampf in der afc im
vorfeld des bundesparteitags in
wiesbaden mitte dezember da wird die
parteispitze neu gewählt die docucolor
scheint trotz des durchwachsenen
wahlergebnisses dadurch ausgesetzt zu
sein jürgen hat offenbar größere
schwierigkeiten sich in der partei zu
behaupten es gibt sehr viel ärger in der
partei und einen wirklichen machtkampf
da jetzt nur durch den bund durch die
bundestagswahl etwas abgemildert war
also die nächsten wochen werden für die
partei entscheid sein der ko-vorsitzende
partei jörg merten der ja bei der
bundestagswahl gar nicht angetreten ist
der wahl zum interview bei phoenix
erneuten prognose sagen 10 11 prozent
für die partei etwas weniger als 2017
wären sie spitzenkandidat gewesen hätten
sie mehr erreicht ich glaube die frage
ist völlig müßig ich bin nicht
spitzenkandidat gewesen ich habe jetzt
noch nicht angestrebt insofern brauchen
wir darüber nicht zu diskutieren
woran lag es denn dass das
bundestagswahlergebnis 2017
offensichtlich nicht erreicht oder dass
die partei sogar stärker abschneidet das
müssen wir analysieren ich bin kein
freund davon am wahlabend dass
rauszuhauen womöglich mit
schuldzuweisungen zu operieren wir
müssen uns das in ruhe anschauen und
müssen eine nachwahlbefragung machen auf
saubere datenbasis land schauen wir
warum es uns nicht gelungen ist das kann
man glaube ich sagen den die
historischen verluste der der cdu
das ehemals konservative kraft auf
unsere mühlen als neue konservativ
freiheitliche kraft umzulenken das haben
offensichtlich andere davon profitiert
als wir das bedauerlich da müssen wir
schauen woran das gelegen hat
schuldzuweisungen ist ein gutes
stichwort
verantwortlich für ein wahlergebnis sind
vor allem die spitzenkandidaten sind ja
zwei bei ihnen deswegen war meine frage
am anfang gar nicht so abwegig gemeint
geht das jetzt vor allen dingen wenn es
eben nicht das ergebnis gebracht dass
sich die afg erhofft hat geht das mit
den beiden spitzenkandidaten nach haus
müssen sich das jetzt
erklärungsbedürftig auch ihr wahlkampf
wir müssen den ganzen balkan analysieren
müssen das wahlprogramm analysieren die
gewalt der spitzenkandidaten aber ich
wäre also ein lausiger parteichef wenn
ich jetzt anfänger mit schuldzuweisungen
an die adresse der spitzenkandidaten das
würde ich für völlig falsch halten wir
müssen uns das in ruhe anschauen woran
hat das gelegen das werden wir auch tun
man muss lernen und wir dürfen nicht
erwarten dass er in einer wahl nach der
anderen ist eine lineare
aufwärtsbewegung gibt die gibt es nicht
es gibt dabei auch mal
konsolidierungsphasen einer solchen sind
ja wohl und da müssen wir schauen wie
wie können wir weiter wachsen das
verlangt eine saubere analyse der daten
zur wahl danach sehen wir weiter es gibt
möglicherweise ja zwei ursachen das eine
ist dass die themen der afd nicht so
gepasst haben müssen sie sich nicht
überlegen wieder themen kader und in
zukunft für die afg anders aufgestellt
wird muss ich nicht breiter aufstellen
wir sind breit aufgestellt und lassen
sie mich sagen ich bin immer über kein
freund davon zu sagen welche themen
haben sie gesetzt die ereignisse setzen
den themen die ereignis hat das thema
aktiv aber nicht mithalten können doch
haben wir wir haben wir zu afghanistan
eine klare position wir haben zu kitten
klare position wir haben zu der
flutkatastrophe und deren ursachen im
dem katastrophalen versagen des
katastrophenschutzes wir haben da sehr
sehr klare position also dieses dieses
flaming das gerne gemacht wer sein der
ein themen partei ist erkennbar unsinnig
wir haben alle themen die die menschen
derzeit umtreiben bespielt und das ist
richtig so nun müssen wir schauen ob wir
die menschen damit erreicht haben wo
waren wir damit erfolgreich wo waren wir
weniger erfolgreich und was müssen wir
anders machen wird der machtkampf in der
afg wieder aufbrechen im vorfeld des
parteitags in wiesbaden da erwarten ja
viele einen showdown mit dem flügel den
sie repräsentieren und dem dänen zum
beispiel blöcke präsentiert das ist eine
geschichte die am wahlabend wirklich
kein thema sein darf wir machen heute
wahl analyse des wahlergebnisses und mit
dem bundesparteitag werden wir uns in
den kommenden wochen beschäftigen ob das
kann nicht jemand das heutige ab die
wahlanalyse von der jungen leuten da
gerade gesprochen hat die geht natürlich
direkt oder leitet genau über zu dieser
macht frage die ich vorhin schon
angesprochen habe in der afd die muss
jetzt geklärt werden in welcher richtung
will sie gehen mit welchem personal will
zu gehen wie stellt sich die
bundestagsfraktion auf wie die partei
wie wird sie bei den nächsten wahlen
bestehen das sind alles offene fragen
die sind nicht geklärt auch die frage
will sich die partei anderen themen
öffnen natürlich ist es sehr stark
fokussiert auf ganz wenige themen und
sieht sie eine bündnis perspektive
ansonsten ist anzunehmen wird die partei
stagnieren stagnieren wird in dem fall
heißen rückschritt aber das sind alles
offene fragen die heute an diesem
wahlabend nicht geklärt worden sind wie
bei den anderen parteien irgendwelchen
das auch allerdings aus anderen gründen
das ist ein vorläufiges resümee ein
fazit hier von der wahlparty der afg wo
wie gesagt niemand fast niemand mehr
anwesend ist zurück ins phoenix
wahlstudio